hey what's up guys my name is the churno
welcome back to the game engine series
specifically to this
first episode of a new format feels good
to be
mixing this series up and introducing
something new because to be honest as as
i mentioned in the video that i put up
yesterday which i'll have a link to over
there i was getting a little bit
uh well a little bit burnt out i guess
with a series and just
didn't really like the way that i was
actually making the videos so in
practice i think
for you people watching not too much is
actually going to change
we're still going to be doing the same
thing i'm still obviously going to try
and keep it as high quality
as possible the only difference is that
this is now going to be more or less
live
by live i don't mean live streamed i
just mean that this is going to be like
the way i'm even recording this is
actually the same way as my like patreon
live stream
setup uh it's just gonna be me working
on hazel i am still going to edit these
videos down a little bit so if there's
like
just stupid moments where i don't know
what i'm doing and there's just gaps and
stuff like that i still
am going to edit it a little bit but
it's just going to be like i have not
like rehearsed this at all i don't know
what i'm going to say i don't know what
i want to do it's just going to be me
working on
hazel and obviously trying to teach you
as much as possible
as i'm working on it which to me is
really exciting because i think that if
i was in your shoes and i was watching
someone make a game engine this is
probably the format
that i would want now i've got my uh
matcha here
which is like a different type of green
tea
because i've been trying to cut down on
my caffeine intake trying to cut down to
one coffee a day
from two so so there we go i've got that
that's just to show you how chill how
chill
this all is so what are we gonna be
doing today um
i really want you guys to watch the
video that i put up yesterday which was
about
the whole kind of game engine series but
also the future of this because
this is going to be the first video in
which we basically
take strides towards our goal which i
have written on the whiteboard up there
which is our priority
which is a full 2d workflow on all
platforms what i mean by that is
we want to be able to make 2d games in
hazel we've picked 2d because
i ran a poll a while ago 51 voted for 2d
but even if you didn't
um it's important to establish i think a
2d workflow first because it's
it's easier uh meaning that like you'll
get it done faster
and especially since i don't have a team
backing me um
i will be able to just physically
program program a 2d workflow a lot
faster than 3d
because 3d is something that is ever
evolving it's something that you know
unity and unreal are still
working on whereas 2d is a lot more
achievable and it will give us basically
the ability to use hazel to create some
kind of interactive uh
game it's just that it will be likely be
2d
now that's what our priority is to
create some to make hazel into a
standalone tool that we can
open we'll open like the hazel engine
and then we'll be able to basically set
up a scene
put some sprites on the screen make some
entities add some behaviors to them via
scripting language
add some components and then export that
into some kind of game that we can run
standalone
outside of the editor as well as
probably preview the game inside the
editor and like some kind of game view
much like unity something like that
um and i haven't figured this out all
the way because even though hazel dev
which is available for patrons even
though that is a lot more advanced than
this version of hazel
and it is 3d um it still hasn't it
doesn't have everything figured out
it's it's got an editor tool but it
still doesn't have everything figured
out
so the strides that i want to take to
make this stuff happen and these videos
um i'm not going to be too stressed on
how long they are i'm definitely going
to keep them under an hour and i'm going
to aim for about half an hour to 40
minutes at a maximum
just because i don't want to dump hours
of footage on new people
uh often because that's a little bit
unwatchable i think and
um i'm sure a few of you would enjoy
that but i think the majority
would much rather something a bit more
condensed and something that
they don't have to allocate hours like
every week or every day or whatever to
watch
so that's why i'm still going to try and
keep these
as concise as possible even though i'm
blabbling on a lot but the reason is
that it's the first episode and i want
to just give a little bit of
i want to formulate a plan because this
is this isn't just
me show like sharing this plan with you
guys it's also me formulating the plan
for myself
because i don't know what i'm doing yet
and that's the whole point to do
everything on camera and in front of you
um so what i want to do is like there
are many things that we
need to do to achieve that 2d workflow
as i've mentioned the first thing is we
need some kind of
tool chain like we need a tool an editor
tool
that we can use to actually basically
you know if you think about it set up
the scene position everything visually
because that's a lot easier to do than
through code
add like a few entities add uh
components to them
add some scripts for behaviors and then
uh you know use the ui to like maybe
set different textures on different
meshes and all of that stuff i mean we
have two
it's 2d so it's not really meshes but we
still have obviously sprites and
and and by the way when i say 2d i think
ultimately
at the end of this maybe we will be
moving the 2d
workflow to a 3d editor so in other
words you'll still be able to possibly
position things in 3d space
but maybe the camera will be locked to a
2d i i'm not sure we'll see what happens
um because i think that if i was making
a 2d game i would maybe try and make it
like 2.5 d
meaning that like you know in the sense
that we'd have like
um maybe you know a bunch of huge matte
paintings or something like that but in
varying kind of zed
planes uh so that we have like basically
like a natural parallax effect and all
these all this other stuff so that
we're not actually confined to working
in two dimensions because that can be
a little bit difficult even if your
final game is supposed to be 3d but
anyway
we'll see i don't want to talk too much
um
let's get into it and let's take a look
and i mean this is so live
that i need to actually hit this button
to transition
to my screen so let me know first of all
what you think of this little like face
cam
because i can get rid of that i can move
it um if it's covering important
information i might move it this is
literally being recorded like in obs
i'm not recording into the camera and
then editing later so it's all very much
live and like a live stream which is
part of the reason why it's so
um i don't know i'm enjoying myself so
far
let's dive into this and take a look at
what we have now also it's worth noting
that um
i'm not going to be recording things i'm
not going to be zooming in and out of
things
so really the best way to watch this is
going to be full screen
when i'm editing code in visual studio
i'll try and zoom in as much as possible
so you can actually see the code
but things like this you know if you
can't read this then
uh please zoom in or watch on a computer
or something like that because this is
meant to be
obviously a view of me developing this
and it's not really realistic for me to
be zooming in
all the time okay so first of all uh
let's
hide the hidden items because i don't
want to see them um i've basically
reverted everything i did in the
little tile based game adventure that we
were working on now
i think most of the stuff is committed
this is fork this is my favorite git
client i think
recently it became it became paid it's
like 50 bucks or something now it used
to be free
i have not paid for it i've still got a
version that i guess you don't need to
pay for
um but to be honest i probably would pay
for it um and just to be clear this is
not sponsored or anything
um but uh it's just a really good sorry
i just had to sneeze there
i'll edit that out probably um fork is a
very good get client i really like it uh
i think that it's yeah it's just really
nice and it has a dark mode for those of
you who are
obsessed with that kind of stuff um okay
so this is um
basically i think where we were up to
but then ah no it's not
my last commit is all the way down here
and you guys can't really see the
authors here
but that's okay it's not really
necessary to see them i think um
or maybe i can get around my face cam by
doing this
anyway so these are all the um different
commits that have gone in
and that's obviously thanks a lot to
lovely santa because he is a
hazel contributor as i've marked him on
my discord server i don't actually know
him but he's done a lot of really good
work so shout out to lovely santa
for helping out with hazel um
he's been merging in various pull
requests and i've basically given him
access and permission to do stuff like
that
so a lot of stuff has gone in here um
i'm not exactly going to
go through all these commits i think i
might i might do that and if you guys
want to see that in a video i guess i
will show that i guess i should show
that
um but looking through all of this stuff
um you know there has been a lot of
changes i wanted to focus on one of them
which i think was specifically uh the
branching instead of it indexing the
texture sampler so
um as far as i'm aware uh you know what
we were doing before
which was basically we had a texture
index which used to be and you guys
might really have to zoom in here
but um uh we had a texture index that we
were passing in which was a float we
were passing it to an in here and using
it as an index into this
sampler 2d array called u textures
inside our fragment shader
to actually sample from the from the
appropriate texture based on
what texture the quad wanted to use this
uh does not work on all gpus and all
drivers um
as far as i'm concerned it works fine
with nvidia
but i think people were saying that for
amd
cards it does not work um now i don't
have
any amd hardware like graphics cards i
mean i've got an amd cpu but
i've got no amd graphics cards in
my house so not because i hate them just
to be clear
but i just don't have them so because of
that
um i have no way of testing this but
people have told me that doesn't compile
so uh we've switched it to this which is
uh i think in sparky that's what i did
in i think opengl es because sparky was
a game engine i made in the past that
ran on android
and because i ran on android i think i
had to do something like this so this is
my preferred strategy for dealing with
this
yes it looks a little bit uh disgusting
but
um i mean you know apparently this is
what needs to happen
we have to basically switch on vtech's
index and then uh you know manually put
this stuff in
which is probably not like the best
thing in the world but that's just a
change that i wanted to kind of
uh you know shout out i guess and just
uh bring to your attention
um yeah so core has been renamed to base
i'm not sure why it's called base in
hazel dev
i believe um for no apparent for no
particular reason just because they're
different code bases
but anyway um so so basically my point
is there's a lot of really helpful stuff
going on in github um
on the repository so thank you to
everyone who's contributing uh
you know the the engine is obviously
better because of the community so
i just wanted to kind of thank you guys
for that let's open up hazel and talk
about what we're going to do today
so what i want to do today is i
basically want to begin
this editor workflow now the reason is
our major kind of goals
are going to be to put in an entity
component system
set up a scene system set up a
serialization system
set up a bunch of components and then
connect up c sharp
that is basically what we need to do and
for that to happen
it would be very useful to have less
temporary ui than we have right now
because at the moment our user interface
is very much just floating windows
everywhere and when we want something we
just bring up an im gui window like this
called settings and it's just it's very
temporary and we'll have to rewrite it
anyway
when we make more of an editor so i
figured why not why not move into an
editor
like now you know why not kind of do
that first
and then when we actually for example
start to
work on the entity component system and
we want to see all of the entities that
are in the scene
all the components attached to a certain
entity we'll just be able to make the ui
for that like
be more permanent because that's part of
the editor so that's my that's my
my thought process here
um and that's ultimately what i want to
do so to set that up
what we need to do is we need to
transition to an imgui
dock space so i am gui um has and this
doesn't even build
so i'm ah it's because i it's because i
got rid of
i reverted some code sub texture to 2d
doesn't exist
i'm pretty sure i pushed that anyway
let's run this again so this is what i
mean like
this is completely live and um you get
to watch me fix
problems so oh and one thing that i
didn't mention
let me switch this to a full screen um
one of the things that i didn't mention
that i really want to to mention
was uh feedback right so this is the
first episode of a new format
please let me know what you think of
this by the end of this
episode if you don't like it let me know
if you like it let me know
um obviously you know this series is
ultimately made for you
so if there's something you want me to
change then i would really appreciate
you telling me um because the other
thing is like um
you know a while ago we tried a
different format where i think i just
basically wrote the code offline and
then i showed the diff
of what i've done and i walked through
that people did not like that whatsoever
and i think within two or three episodes
we went back to
writing all the code live so you know i
do care what you think
and i would like to know um in general
you know uh if you're happy with this
format if you think it's
better but not quite there yeah just
yeah just let me know and
i will uh fix it up okay so um
let's try and compile this code that's
gonna be our goal for today too
okay that was quick um so now we have
this stuff
up up and running and i'm going to be
looking over here on my other monitor
sometimes just to make sure the face
caps are in the way and yeah regarding
the face cam let me know i'm happy to
get rid of it
um so but i guess this builds more of a
connection and sometimes when i'm
talking and
not actually doing anything it probably
is better anyway so
we have floating windows which is good
floating windows means that we can
render windows i'm going windows outside
of the main area
so in other words this actually creates
like a new window on the fly and renders
stuff into there
that's really good that means that we're
obviously using the imgui docking branch
because that's something that exists
there now that should mean that if we
look at imgui demo
this actually should have and this is a
very good file to consult when you're
working with i'm gui
because this has like basically this is
like a full test suite
for i am gui everything that i'm gooey
is capable of this should basically
support
so what that means is that and it's very
easy to deal with all you really have to
do is say
i am gui show demo window
um if you want to you know uh if you
actually want to look at something
so i'll just you know say show equals
true
and put show into this and then if we
run this then we should be able to
see the show demo window and i'm
bringing that up on purpose for
something as you'll see in a minute
if i click on examples and dock space
this is what i'm interested in
so this is the i'm gui dock space um and
you can see that it's really been here
all along
this i'm gui dock space you can see
first of all our scene has completely
disappeared
okay that's step one because i'm gooey
has taken over our entire window step
two is if i drag windows around
we have these wonderful docking
indicators here that let us dock this
what that means is i can easily dock
this into here i can take this
settings window this actually isn't part
of the dock space so i can't do anything
with this
that's okay if i spawn like another
window
i think i can see i can put this like
over here or over here and you can see
pretty eas pretty quickly here
that what i'm actually doing is let's go
console
is i'm actually setting up basically a
tool
here that could be like a level editor
we've got like you know this example
over here
we've got this dim gui demo panel over
here you know i can
uh sport i think you guys get the point
but i'll show you one more thing
i don't know if simple overlays is what
i necessarily wanted to do i think i
just ruined everything
right click to change position close
that's what position i want
not present okay i opened it again what
is wrong with me
okay main menu bar and you can see we
have file
and open and i mean we quit which
doesn't do anything luckily
um you know we have like this whole
there's a property editor example here
where this is very similar to the
property grid
that i kind of designed i guess in um
like for hazel dev you can you basically
see the point like we have
um we have uh something that more or
less could be a tool so we need to
transition
um hazel and in the current format to
using basically
this kind of view now it's not very hard
to do
but it is something that i haven't done
in like probably over a year because
that's when i did it to hazeldev
so what we're going to do is we're going
to actually show this
demo i'm going to go to this demo window
and then in here
i guess i'm just going to search for
dock space
so show example app dock space so this
is kind of what i want
um i'm going to this should be more or
less self-contained so i can literally
copy this hopefully
um and we can analyze this code because
this is the example code
i'm going to kind of analyze this code
and figure out how we can put it in here
now obviously right now we're inside
sandbox just to be clear sandbox is
intended to be the runtime
this is not intended to be like the
editor tool we're going to make
another tool called hazelnut um
i don't know if i'm actually going to
keep that name um maybe we'll just call
it hazel editor or something
a little bit like more like that but in
the dev branch i've got hazelnut which
is like the hazel editor and then hazel
is obviously the runtime and then you
know
like the sandbox project is the run time
but what we're ultimately going to do is
create a new project called
hazelnut i don't want to do that today
i'll probably do that next time because
right now my priority is just to set up
this dock space
so uh that being said what i want to do
is probably paste that code in
like here to begin with see if we get
any errors
so open we get open as an error um
but i think now we've got a few other
errors help marker we don't need the
help marker
uh show docking disabled message we
don't need because docking will not be
disabled
um because we'll start that we'll start
that up as part of the i'm going state
and then finally
uh docking being open i mean
i don't know what i did for hazel dev
but i'm sure this could probably just be
like true or something i mean we need to
pass in an
actual uh optical screen because
persistent so opt full screen
i'm not sure exactly what this is again
we'll have to like look at this in more
detail but doc
space open i'll set to true
and then this will be something that
i pass in here so now we've okay we've
got a few other things here
so close dock space it sets dock space
open to false which could be
like a cool thing to do um what's dock
space open
that that's that why are we
dereferencing that though
what used to happen here doc space open
used to be a
i used to be p open and what p open used
to be a
oh p open was a ball that we passed in i
see okay so now this has changed
um let's see enabled
will always be enabled and then we can
just say
dock space open uh
is false alright so if we launch this
now
then we should probably just see the
dock space and we do
right so we've lost our scene which is
good um now we can't dock this settings
panel
why is that so we need to uh talk about
that
so as far as i'm concerned in order to
be able to dock things um i think
we need to so this is a i'm going to
begin
dock space demo um i think we need to
we basically need need to i don't think
they
okay here's a little test i guess i'm
fairly sure that
maybe all the windows that we create
have to be
inside the dock space but i'm not really
sure if that's the case
um but maybe it is yeah i think it is
so this window settings now we've we've
basically moved it to be before
the dock space ends which is this end
this is the end for the dock space
so what that means is that this window
now you can see if i drag it around it's
dockable
so i can just put it here and it's now
part of this i can
put it make it full screen like this i
can put it on the top i can
do whatever i want with it because it's
now kind of a dockable
uh panel so that that's an important
thing to do and obviously we can still
kind of
just pull that out and put it into like
somewhere else put onto like our other
monitor if we're dealing with a multiple
monitor setup
so it's really useful and obviously kind
of what we expect and if we hit close
dock space okay that didn't really work
i thought that would work
but anyway it doesn't matter we're not
gonna have a button called closed dock
space
and we're not gonna to be honest we're
not gonna have like this whole like
begin menu bar end menu bar we're not
actually gonna have
this here um we can probably begin a
menu called file
and then have like one menu item here
called like quit or exit or something
like that
um and then uh
okay let's see menu item exit
okay no shortcut selected uh
so what is this we don't really need
anything we can just write exit i guess
and then if it's pressed we can just you
know
how do we okay i don't think we can
actually close hazel at the moment
cleanly um because what happens is
application we have a
running basically on window closed
that's running to false
so what we could do is application like
shutdown or application
close um let's just add that in right
now why not
so avoid close so this will shut down a
hazel application
i don't want to call it shutdown because
shutdown sounds very serious
and it sounds like um it basically just
sounds like
a system shutdown or something whereas
close is like the user wants to close it
that's how i see that at least
so now what we should be able to do is
on exit we can just do
application get dot
close all right and then this will
obviously be hazel
we won't have to deal with this
hazelname space everywhere because
hazelnuts or the editor will be part of
the hazel namespace
so i'm not too worried about that um
this is just me checking to
see if this will work just for fun
really so now we have a file menu and we
have an exit
button and we can press the exit button
okay fantastic the other thing i wanted
to briefly talk about was the font
um i don't think we're going to spend
too much time on that
now but um this default i am going theme
and i'm going font
i'm not the biggest fan of so i will be
changing that to something that doesn't
look like
a monos based font just because like
there's no need for it to look like this
and i'm
again i'm just not the biggest fan of
this um but uh
yeah probably something we can talk
about next time um okay
so now that we've done that the next big
stage
in this whole kind of uh i guess
dock space thing is we want to be able
to
create a viewport and and that viewport
needs to be able to um basically we need
to render our scene
to that viewport and then that viewport
itself is going to be an i'm going
window
that we can then put in now to do
something like
that um we basically do need to extend
the renderer a little bit
i think because we don't support frame
buffers at the moment
the idea is and this is how viewports
work in i'm gui
um well not really an i'm gui in
anything really what we want to do is
render our entire scene
into a frame buffer and thus into a
texture
and then once we have that texture we
can use imgui's image view to actually
render that
so as an example because i know we have
textures like checkerboard texture for
example
we can actually as part of this i think
we can just do i am gui
image and then we need a user texture id
so we can say
what's the renderer how do we get the
render id from a texture is that
something that our api doesn't support
because it should no it doesn't okay
let's add something we'll have it as a
un-32t
for now but it's probably worth creating
maybe
a like you know some kind of renderer id
um type there for like a using that
basically will
well not maybe not using but maybe some
kind of struct that basically will
contain um
the render id no matter what uh
rendering api we're dealing with
but basically uh get render id here and
it'll be virtual obviously
so this function if we go into
text gl texture and we only have the 2d
one
then this will be override this will
return m renderer id
so now we can just do get renderer
renderer id and then for the size
um what size should we use i am back to
let's do like let's do like 64 by 64 or
something that might be a little slow i
mean a little small
um this is incompatible with i am
texture id
uh that's fine what is iron texture id
iron texture id
is a void pointer okay that's fine
that's just because i'm going
also supports various apis so we can
just say um 32t
uh texture id
um and this texture id so it wants a
void pointer
now i'm fairly sure that what it
actually wants is
that it does not want us to give it like
the memory address of this or something
like that
so if we if we run this we should
hopefully be able to see our
checkerboard texture
as part of our um like settings panel i
guess
and there it is so there's that
checkerboard texture we were drawing it
quite small
let's just do to like 256 or something
so you can see it better
but basically that's the idea right so
what we want to do is we want to draw
um this but this is going to be our
scene view
so this is going to be our scene um it's
not going to be
a checkerboard texture it's going to be
our scene and we're going to draw it on
it on
it's like in its own panel and the size
also is going to be dependent
on the size of the panel so that's a few
things that we need to set up but i
think i will leave that for
next time so to summarize and i will be
pushing all this code of course to
github what we've done is we've set up a
dock space and our plan right now is to
set up
like an editor um i guess workflow so
what we're going to do next time is
we're going to
probably construct like a frame buffer
class and we're going to
um once we have a frame buffer class
we're going to have a texture attachment
onto that frame buffer
which we could then take and then use
as that kind of iron gui image that we
can render as part of like a panel
so that is the plan um now regarding
as well these videos one more thing that
i wanted to add was
i do still want to keep them fairly like
uh i guess based on a particular topic
so every video should be based on like
one or two topics it shouldn't be like
you know a video that's 40 minutes long
in which we do five completely different
things
so i do still want to split up the
videos based on what they're about so
this was kind of about the imgui dock
space
but then the next video will probably be
about creating frame buffers and then
the video after that will be about
um you know basically creating that i'm
blue viewport now that we have a frame
buffer class set up and all of that
stuff
just so that people can obviously find
what they're looking for and they don't
need to like
you know we can keep the videos more
bite-sized and more kind of
i guess tailored to specific features
that we add into
hazel so that does not mean that i'm
definitely gonna stick to like one video
per week schedule
if it's a smaller video like this one i
will probably release another one fairly
soon
because at the moment as i mentioned my
priorities to get this working as soon
as possible
so hopefully i will uh have time to make
more of these throughout the week
instead of just the one
kind of every thursday as i've been
doing but i hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please hit that like
button don't forget
thank you that you can help support uh
hazel hazel dev
everything that i'm doing here on
youtube i'm going to patreon for the
cherno
uh you'll get access to live streams
which look basically exactly the same as
this
except it's more or less me uh working
on hazel dev the 3d version and
obviously it's live streams i'm
interacting with chat and all of that
stuff
and you'll also get access to uh the
hazel dev
code where i have basically built like a
3d
version of hazel with like a level
editor and it's a lot more advanced than
this and you can take it and take a look
at that
and obviously that will help support
this series as well
thank you all for watching i enjoyed
this i will see you next time goodbye
[Music]
you